welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of HBO's
The Last of Us episode 2 infected the
interesting visual details connections
to the game and deeper layers of meaning
you know what I did mention last week
that clicker visible on the rooftop in
the final shot but you better believe
Joel Elliott tested and missed him and
his friends this episode with their
mistletoe moves but hey I did get that
flower Theory right my follow-up short
and you know what a few of you even
called me a dummy for saying the
infection was spread by flower code
Hollywood handshakes but it's all good
we're gonna break down everything you
missed and for more of my deeper
analysis please subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive and
whichever week I'll investigate titles
like everything everywhere at once so
the more pointed Focus it's launching
February 17th okay episode 2 opens in
Jakarta Indonesia which came up on a
radio broadcast last episode
it's September 24th 2003 two days before
outbreak day and you can already hear
siren starting
in this restaurant we see close-ups of
flower-based food in people's dishes but
it is eating only skewered meat and a
salad when these officers enter all the
patrons go silent now in 2003 Indonesia
was under a period of Reform under
President megawati sukarno putry but
this was right after a tumultuous new
order period that lasted from 1966 to 98
under sukato who's a military dictator
these patrons would definitely be old
enough to remember a time when badges
showing up during lunch meant trouble
just really really like this detail the
officer hidayat apologizes for
interrupting the lunch and IBU says no
need she was just finishing cautiously
abundant courtesy because both of these
people are scared out of their minds
they're wanting the other one to like
them since they believe the other holds
their life in their hands now IBU is a
professor of mycology the study of fungi
the front desk translates to Ministry of
Health of Indonesia and we pass science
for SARS which earlier that year
February 2003 was the bigger infection
of concern a respiratory virus largely
in China The Authority tells IBU to
identify the specimension
yeah it's clear that it was brought in
as a second opinion and they are hoping
for better news from her in general I
love this intro because many associate
infections from other countries with a
kind of xenophobic hypochondria oh no
can I even like drink the water in that
country but we see here that it wasn't
immediate chaos in the streets of
Jakarta an academic expert in ground
zero diagnosed it immediately and still
could not stop it IBU examines his
corpse and first notices a bullet wound
in the head not a good sign she makes an
incision on the leg revealing a layer of
cordyceps tissue directly beneath the
skin which is crazy it's like the
stuffing of a plush toy this means it's
not muscle tissue that's moving the
limbs of the infected it's just all
fungus tendrils underneath there and she
checks the throat and yuck living
cordyceps tendril reaches out for a hug
even through ibu's plastic protective
suit the fungus knows that she's there
as she plays in the room the tendrils
continue to reach upward out of the
mouth this scene reminded me a lot of
the autopsy scene in The Silence of the
Lambs when they realize that the moth
cocoon wasn't better than the victim's
throat it's sickening but it's also the
key clue that Clarice later uses to
identify Buffalo Bill and here in this
scene foreshadowing the kiss of death
that will take tests the diet confirms
the transmission happened 30 hours prior
at a flower and grain Factory on the
west side of Jakarta and IBU calls it
the perfect substrate the substrate
meaning a surface or material on which
an organism can live this confirms my
theory that the fungus is spread by
flour in the food supply Jakarta has the
world's largest Flour Mill and last
episode Sarah noted that they were out
of pancake mix the adlers offer biscuits
that Joel turned down Ms Adler makes
raisin cookies that Sarah hates we get a
close-up of the heat rising and those
cookies growing and later that night
Joel forgets to pick up cake now this
shot of IBU is an extended multi minute
take and I just love that we never cut
away and we have to stay with her in
this war for this whole unbroken moment
IBU attempts some contact tracing
learning that they don't know who bit
the woman before the Factory and then
learns
Partners around here
[Music]
yeah the moment she hears 14 her hand
rattles the T she never takes the sip of
it either afraid to ingest anything like
Dr Newman in episode 1 IBU says that
there is no treatment possible and
instead just looks at this military
officer to give him one solution that
he'll understand boom
yeah and I like how even in other
language the word is the same bomb and
it's the same solution the Americans try
on their own cities is this where they
bombed
yeah
they hit most of the big cities like
this they had to slow the spread somehow
worked here but it didn't in most places
so then we opened on Ellie sleeping in
the fetal position surrounded by green
moss just a pure Natural State like a
fetus in utero the next stage of human
evolution potentially resisted to the
fungus a butterfly flaps Pastor we're
calling the butterflies on Sarah's
pillowcase as Ellie supplants Sarah as
the daughter figure that Joel must
protect butterflies are symbols of
transformation from the caterpillar to
the Cocoon Metapod to Butterfree and as
the world goes through biological
Transformations around them these
characters must undergo psychological
transformations in order to adapt and to
survive change is inevitable now this
room used to be a salon you look at the
door that's Super Cuts this will be a
place where you do get makeovers and
transform your look that's a magazine
that you flip through for hairstyle
inspiration that test tosses Ellie to
use toilet paper now like Professor IBU
Joel's hand also trembles but from his
Savage beating in that Soldier the night
before he is shaking because For the
First Time in decades he feels something
stop talking about this kid like she's
got some kind of life in front of her
he's trying to stifle the affection he's
feeling by liking Nelly with Sarah and
how quickly Sarah's future was snuffed
out now Tess is really interesting to
watch in this scene because notice how
overnight she's become a True Believer
she
doesn't matter Craig Mason and Neil
druckman reveal that they actually wrote
and shot a whole backstory for tests
that they ultimately removed Tess was a
wife and a mother and both her husband
and her son got abducted she had to kill
her husband but she couldn't bring
herself to kill her kid so she just
locked him in the basement and
presumably he's now a clicker according
to Mason so Tess's nuke found Hope for
Ellie her hope for Redemption and for
all the [__] she's done is grounded in
what she did to her family
post-apocalyptic Boston looks incredible
with vines growing out everywhere from
the crumbling buildings and the
corroding cars really smart VFX detail
here Joel's head blocks out a glare from
a background building window tricking
our brains into thinking everything in
the background is practical and
affecting us physically when in reality
that leaning skyscrapers totally bfx
like in the game the atmosphere is
immersive and the production designers
just did a really good job blending the
foreground practical sets in the
background VFX so you don't really know
where the line is the police car they
pass is the Boston PD Ford Expedition
the make model and paint job even that
Suffolk County cops use in the year 2003
they also stepped past a stuffed giraffe
which could be a nod to the draft app
that you run into and give a good boy
Pat in the game Ellie tells Tess that
she was bitten after sneaking into the
boarded up Mall in the QC so it was just
you in there alone
yeah
yeah Ellie sniffs because there is more
to that story which I'll get to at the
end in spoiler Corner Ellie also shares
some myths that she's heard so there
aren't super infected that explode
fungus spores on you [__] I hope not
or ones with split open heads that stay
in the dark like bats ah the second kind
refers to clickers and yeah definitely
we're gonna meet a few of them in this
episode I'll talk about the various
stages of infected and spoiler corner
just in case you'd want to be surprised
by what's coming I love how this hotel
has become an entirely new ecosystem a
swampy Pond a frog purchased on the keys
of the piano creating a diegetic horror
score
later Ellie adds to this music when she
gets scared by the corpse
every bottle and glass they pass in the
hotel now has plant life growing out of
it as water and nutrients would have
collected inside and created a sort of
petri dish ecosystem for life to form
Joel gives tests a boost that she can
crawl through the cave in Joel and Tess
giving each other boosts and pulling
each other up on Ledges like this it's
just a common move that you do in this
early section of the game Joel and Ellie
have this moment alone Ellie asks how
long infected Live Well some last about
a month or two
but there's others been walking around
but 20 years yeah bit of foreshadowing
for some long time infected hosts
who's Funk growing and growing again oh
it's
the three of them look down see rows of
an infected laying down below the last
time we were here they were still deep
inside the buildings
and I guess enough people came through
looking for the qz he went inside so you
can shelter
and that's how they get more and more in
the city bit by bit year after year ah
so this tells us that the Boston QC is
not necessarily secure permanently it
explains why Joel and Tess were ready to
leave it even before meeting Ellie now I
love to eat what I do not love is trying
to figure out what to eat I get confused
when I get hungry and it makes figuring
out how to get unhungry particularly
tricky that's why I love taking the
guesswork out of what I'm gonna eat by
using factor in the past you might have
heard me say something similar for
hellofresh well factor is now owned by
hellofresh I use both and it's great
Factor not only lets me skip the trip to
the grocery store but I also get to skip
chopping prepping and cleaning up Factor
meals already in two minutes so all you
gotta do is just heat and enjoy each
meal is prepared by chefs and approved
by dietitians so you know they have all
the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long no matter what
your diet calls for Factor heads keto
calorie smart vegan vegetarian and
Protein Plus meals on the menu each week
Factor has 34 weekly options so there's
always something new to try plus you can
round out your meal and replenish your
snack Supply with an assortment of over
36 quick bites smoothies juices and more
satisfying add-ons so this month I got
this shredded chicken cheesy ranch bacon
cheesy bacon ranch shredded chicken I
call dibs on this one I like cheesy I
like shredded I like bacon and I like
Ranch we got jalapeno lime cheddar
chicken we're giving this one to Kelly
because she loves loves loves jalapeno I
got a cottage pie I'm dying to try out I
got some busili I can't wait to eat but
I tried out the shredded chicken and
folks it blew my mind oh that is so good
this is without question the easiest way
to eat healthy delicious food without
becoming the numbers lady meme at the
grocery store to get started just head
to factor75.com or click the link below
and use code rockstars60 to get 60 off
your first Factor box once more that's
factor75.com and use code rockstars60 to
get 60 off your first Factor box the
infected all react to sunlight in a wave
they're connected more than you know the
fungus also grows underground long
fibers like wires some of them
stretching over a mile when you step in
a patch of cordyceps in one place and
you can wake a dozen affect it from
somewhere else okay so this whole idea
of cordyceps hive mind like the neural
chemical network of Pandora and Avatar
is a new thing in the HBO series it's
not something really in the game or at
least not established yet we probably
know by now if it was but to be clear
when we're using a term like hive mind
we should separate the idea of Mind from
the idea of cognition behind the scenes
that new rock stars or sales guy Berg
was giving me amazing lecture on this
subject both the idea of a mind and the
idea of cognition are metaphysical
Concepts debated by scientists
especially when it comes to things like
AI so it's not that fungi are sentient
the way humans are in our working
collectively to outsmart us and Hunt us
but they do collectively react to
environmental stimuli and are capable as
a colony of living for years and years
and years and accomplishing some complex
things but at that point you get to the
debate of well are humans just reacting
to environmental stimuli I don't know I
get hungry at sundown sleepy at midnight
and every time my wife revs up the
microwave a piece of pants forget who I
am for a half hour so but this change to
the show accomplishes two things one
there's some thematic takeaway here that
cordyceps is beating us by being more
communicative and better connected than
humanity is like arguably the more
worthy species of taking over planet
Earth but two it gives the fungi a range
threat that you could say they lose by
the show omitting the Spore component of
them this is just a new way that the
fungus can get us you're not immune from
being ripped apart now in the museum
they pass displays of the Boston Tea
Party and portraits of bounding fathers
all covered in dried cordyceps as if all
of American History was rendered
pointless by a fungal infection that
swallowed our entire Society the
infected corpses they passed still bear
some human features that are just eerily
preserved because as we saw before the
muscle tissue beneath the skin gets
replaced by the fungus so that delays
the decomposition that our bodily fluids
would have caused they ended up trapped
in a room with two clickers now these
are the blind infected individuals
formed by the fungus splitting over
their heads and like bats they use
echolocations like clicks to perceive
their surroundings
oh
now last week my buddy Ryan area at
screen Crush pointed out the motif of
ticking clocks in the episode 1
flashbacks and you may have noticed when
Sarah dies Joel's watch breaks and
freezes on the exact moment of her death
and now in this moment I loved hearing
how the Clockwork ticking to the old
world has been replaced with sporadic
random clicking of the clickers because
now time truly has no meaning Ellie
though is unable to silence her own gasp
notice how this flicker compared to
other infected runners or stalkers wears
clothes that are more worn down because
that's because to get like this clickers
must have been affected for over a year
longer than most other infected that we
see his wet and slimy head has had its
skull split down to the top row of teeth
in the palette but the fungus has
otherwise left the mouth intact because
it needs the mouth for oral transmission
when Joel shoots the chest it's
ineffective because the fungus doesn't
feel pain and really doesn't need any of
the vital organs that would have been in
the chest region only really the brain
the brain stem Joel removes the bullets
from his revolver
foreign
just a little sound of the shells alerts
that clicker and I love how the camera
stays on Joel as the clicker starts to
move toward us but frames it out so that
like Joel We just have to guess where it
is
[Music]
and they upped the volume on those
clicks to signal to us that he is now
just a few feet away around the corner
so Joel having faced these things before
knows how to use the clicker's own
echolocation methods to echolocate it
and notice how we don't see where Tess
is for most of the sequence or how she
loses her clicker just a little warning
sign something probably went down off
screen with her now Tess says there's no
going back home notice how their path
through this Museum caves in behind them
which is similar to the experience of
playing the game and many games really
your path closes off behind you and
there's only one path forward it's just
so sad to re-watch this episode from
here forward for in Taurus performance
like when Joel raps tape around her foot
and she just looks at him with tears in
her eyes there's probably more ahead
so we'll deal with it then Tess gets a
moment alone and her hand does twitch a
bit not sure if it's voluntary or not
but muscle spasms are a symptom and
notice how Tess Yelps in pain when her
arm on the side where the bite is grabs
the ladder Joel after watching Ellie go
down the ladder very suddenly looks down
at his watch unable to look at Ellie
without thinking of his daughter Sarah
Tess walks ahead of them toward the
State House more in a rush than they are
and to hide her shoulder bite that's not
when she turns around you can see blood
sprayed on her neck Joel doesn't notice
because he's too busy looking at Ellie's
more recent scratch worried that she's
going to turn so when they get to the
state house they find everyone dead
already which is another contrast from
the games and the games Tess has to hold
all this down as dangerous soldiers come
in and there's a big shootout but like
last episode this series shows the
heroes in the present day stumbling upon
the aftermath of the human vs human
shootouts instead of taking down person
after person like you do sometimes in
the game except for specific moments
from Joel here Joel explains what
happened one of them got bit the healthy
ones fought the sick ones everyone lost
and test reveals her infected bite in
comparison to Ellie scratch it has no
effect this is real
Josh is real
I need you to get her to Bill and
Frank's and yes Tessa's hand trimmer is
more severe now Tess says I I never ask
you for anything not to feel the way I
felt not too no you shut the [__] up
because I don't have time it's just so
tragic in her final minutes she doesn't
even have time to profess her love for
Joel because she knows that they missed
their window and she continues you get
her there you're alive
said everything right
yes Tess sees the promise of Joel
getting Ellie to safety in a possible
cure to cordyceps as her one hope for
Redemption Joel shoots the infected host
and the cordyceps in the soil latches
onto his hands see the fungal Colony at
work similar tendril snake under a
fingernail lifted a little ugh I know I
know I know but the dinner bell has been
rung actually the stalker we see here up
close is the same one that'll eventually
plant the smooch on tests Tess sets up
the place to blow up and has this final
moment with Joel
foreign
[Music]
you can tell that Joel totally wants to
give her a goodbye kiss right now but at
this point a kiss with an infected is a
kiss of death so this is the closest
they get and all the infected arrive
this stalker closes in for a kiss and ah
in addition to the undeniable grossness
of the tendril transmission it's just an
additional violation because a kiss is
such an intimate gesture now this
actor's name Philip Raju and look how
far this guy looks when you lose that
fungal makeup uh hello there so This
Kiss just feels like an especially cruel
perversion reminding me of the overtly
sexual design of the xenomorph Anatomy
an alien this is another example of the
showrunner's subversive theme of the
series the danger of Love This Kiss is a
loving gesture and even from the
perspective of the cordyceps it is a
kind of loving embrace it's one piece of
the fungus recognizing and connecting
with another piece of the fungus yet
that love is destructive and violent
let's never forget that but Tess is able
to bring the suffering to an end by
finally igniting the lighter push C
drops thanks to her hands muscle spasms
and so the room explodes bringing us
back to Professor ebu's only real
solution to deal with the infected bomb
okay on to spoiler corner for those of
you who know what's coming to the games
or for those of you don't really mind I
will give additional warnings for any
big
GS character deaths or other big twists
the show has not indicated at all and so
for the spoiler corner it's just gonna
be some general knowledge that some may
consider to be fun surprises for the
coming episodes which is why I put it
here okay so yeah Ellie was not the only
one in the mall Riley was there with her
but like Joel not wanting to talk about
Sarah Ellie doesn't want to talk about
her lost loved one notice how Ellie also
indicated no boyfriend is Gonna Come
looking for her and then Ellie's mention
of super infected that explode fungus
spores on you that test and Joel thought
was a myth totally an odd to bloaters
one of which shows up in the trailer so
we know a bloater is coming floaters are
the several year old infected hosts with
fungal layers that have formed like
armor and tear chunks of that fungus opt
themselves to throw like Spore bombs
actually early in the game there is a
bedroom handout showing the stages of
infected from Runner to stalker to
clicker to and then the bloater stage
torn off now there's also a stage
infected later in the games called
shamblers that are found near water that
spray Spore clouds but really in general
this whole talk of a hive mind and some
Infected being 20 years old the full
length of the pandemic maybe the show at
least indicating to viewers or people
who have played part two that things are
gonna eventually get to the Rat King
from part two of the games the Rat King
is a freakish 20 year old beast in the
Seattle area made up of multiple
infected hosts used together is one of
the most frightening bosses of the game
while I definitely don't think the Rat
King is going to come in season one this
has got to be something the show is
going to get to in season two or season
three hey a reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive launching
February 17th you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]